- This looks like a big baguette,
but it's not.
It's a giant log of cookie.
(upbeat music)
Hey, what's up?
My name is Tway, and
welcome to "Making it Big",
the show where we take your favorite foods
and turn it giant,
colossal,
gargantuan.
(high-pitched tone)
I have a very special guest today,
and it just happens to be her birthday,
so I really have to do a great job
at whatever she challenges me to do.
So let's give it up for the birthday girl!
(crew cheers)
Welcome.
What do I see in your hands?
- Only one of my favorite
childhood snacks.
Pocky!
- Interesting.
These are actually the opposite of big.
They're pretty small.
- They're so small. Yeah.
- How big do we want this?
- Humongous.
Like a light saber.
- Flavor wise, what flavors
are we working with?
- Chocolate, matcha, strawberry,
and cookies and cream.
- Oh, these are really good flavors.
- I got good taste.
- Do you want me to pick one?
- All of them.
- Oh.
- You're Tway, so you can do it.
(Tway laughs)
I'm very excited.
This will be the best birthday gift ever.
I really appreciate you.
Good luck.
- Thanks.
- [Jasmine] Good luck.
(Tway sighs)
- Let's do this.
(jazzy music)
The fact that I have
this mountain of butter
and this mountain of flour
and it all has to be used
is a little bit daunting.
I have to nail this
shortbread cookie dough.
Two pounds of flour.
It's gonna go right
into my food processor.
About a cup of sugar,
a tablespoon of baking powder,
one and a half teaspoons of kosher salt.
Worried for this machine,
'cause it might overheat,
but keep a close eye on it.
(processor whirs)
Okay, and then one pound
of butter right into here.
Okay, I'm gonna give this a pulse.
(processor whirs)
Most of the equipment here that we have
aren't really equipped to make big food.
I'm gonna try my best to not break it.
(processor whirs)
So this mixture has
gotten a little bit flaky,
so I'm gonna add my vanilla into the milk.
Whisk it together
and drizzle it in.
(processor whirs)
(processor squeals then stops)
Okay, well it just decided
to stop on its own.
Sorry.
Didn't mean to bother.
But this looks so good!
By the way,
this is only one batch for one dough,
and it's only vanilla.
We actually have to make
a chocolate dough as well.
I have a lot of work to do,
but we're off to a really good start.
I wanna shape my dough,
and it's gonna be great.
I hope Jasmine is hungry,
'cause this is only one Pocky.
Oh, man.
The blade chopped off
a little bit of my spatula.
You know, extra flavor.
I'm using a sieve to dust my flour
so there are no lumps.
I can't believe that this
is actually just one Pocky.
This...
It's already so massive!
Shortbread cookies are
very tricky to begin with
and they're very delicate.
So I know that this is a very
sensitive boy right here.
It's wanting to fall apart.
I'm gonna let this sit in the fridge
so it can firm up.
That way, it'll be easier
for me to roll it out.
One vanilla batch down.
I'm going to put this in
the fridge for an hour.
While I wait for that,
I'm gonna make five
more batches of vanilla
and then I can get
started on my chocolate.
(jazzy music)
Now all I gotta do are
my chocolate batches.
The process is pretty much the same thing.
The only difference is
I'm adding cocoa powder
to this batch.
(processor whirs)
I don't know if it's
because I have experience
just making this dough,
but this is becoming really easy to do.
Okay, adding in my vanilla to my milk.
I think that was the
fastest dough I've made yet.
It's looking good, guys.
Looking great.
Growing up in Vietnam,
there wasn't any Pocky,
but there was something similar.
It's just like shortbread cookie sticks
and then on the side
there would be sugar dips
or chocolate dips.
I didn't have a proper Pocky stick
until I came over to America,
and that was life-changing.
Alright, this is going in the fridge.
I have one more to go and I can move on.
(upbeat music)
Apparently, Pocky was first sold in 1966.
That's actually not that long ago.
There are technically
over 50 Pocky flavors.
Here is my chilled batch of vanilla.
This is my chilled batch of chocolate.
So after one hour in the fridge,
it's definitely really firm.
I'm gonna roll this out,
about 30 to 31 inches long
and then about two inches wide.
I start in the middle right here,
and just kind of use my fingers
to spread out the dough.
I just hope that this dough
doesn't spread too much when it's baking
because I really need
it to keep its shape.
(energetic music)
This looks like a big baguette,
but it's not.
It's a giant log of cookie.
I'm really scared it's not
going to hold its shape.
What I'm gonna do is I'm going to wrap it,
and keep it wrapped while it's baking
so it can keep its shape.
For those of you at home
that are worried that
the plastic will melt,
since this is such a big batch of cookie,
while it's baking,
it's going to create a lot of steam,
and the steam is going to
keep the plastic from melting.
Also, make sure that the ends are tight.
It's like a big compound butter.
Really happy about this.
I'm gonna wrap it in aluminum.
I have seven more to go.
Once all of this is rolled out,
I'm gonna put it into the
oven at 300 for 90 minutes.
(upbeat music)
While the giant Pocky sticks are baking,
I'm gonna work on my toppings.
I have dried strawberries here
and Oreos that I'm gonna crush up
to make these two flavors,
because Jasmine wants all of them.
I'm gonna do strawberries first.
These are freeze-dried strawberries.
Run it through a food processor.
(processor whirs)
Then I'm gonna run it through a sieve
so there are no chunks in here.
Oh, that looks so good!
These will be for the Pocky sticks,
and this will be for my snack later.
Now, I'm going to add in my Oreos
for the cookies and cream.
(processor whirs)
Super happy with this.
It's actually kind of sticking together
because of the cream.
Ta-da!
I'm nervous.
(Tway laughs)
I'm about to work with an
insane amount of chocolate.
It's gonna be tough.
Guys, I was not kidding
when I said there's going
to be a lot of chocolate,
because this is a whole lot of chocolate.
I have ruby chocolate,
semi-sweet chocolate,
and white chocolate.
The white chocolate is
for the cookies and cream
and matcha flavor.
I have to melt all of it,
and I'm gonna start with
the semi-sweet chocolate.
(grinder clatters)
Sorry. That was really loud.
I'm trying not to make my water boil
because if my water starts to boil,
it will ruin the chocolate.
So I'm trying to keep it at a simmer.
Working with a big giant
spatula is very tiring,
because I can't even hold it
like a regular spatula.
I'm holding it like it's just a big stick.
This is actually a cheater
way of tempering chocolate,
adding coconut oil,
because this is a really
big batch of chocolate
that I don't want to mess up and waste.
So tempering is basically
getting chocolate
to a right melted temperature,
which is really tricky
because it can bloom
and it can start to seize up
and you can't use that chocolate anymore.
If your temperature's too low,
the chocolate will melt very slow
and it will be a pain in the butt.
The chocolate's looking really good,
nice and silky.
I hope Jasmine's gonna be happy
because we're going all out
with all of the chocolate flavors
for her birthday.
I have my white chocolate here,
and the first flavor that
I'm gonna do is matcha.
Whisk all of this together.
Mm. I love the smell of matcha.
It's turning out to look
like the actual color
of the matcha Pocky stick,
and I'm really happy about it.
That's matcha.
Next up, I have my Oreo crumbles here.
I'm gonna flavor this chocolate,
and that's for the
cookies and cream Pocky.
Just going to add like two pinches
of this crumble in here.
Going for that speckled look.
I want it to be kind of like a peek-a-boo,
not like, "Hey! I'm here!"
You know?
I gotta work fast here,
'cause I don't want
this chocolate to harden
and ruin all my hard work.
(jazzy music)
Hi, my name is Tway,
and welcome to my chocolate shop.
(Tway laughs)
This is a lot of chocolate.
We have our semi-sweet chocolate here,
ruby chocolate,
our cookies and cream,
and our matcha.
The only thing missing
are my giant Pocky sticks.
So...
Check this out.
(drum roll)
Ta-da!
(crowd cheering sounds)
They held up.
I'm so happy about that.
Okay, these are really, really big.
I'm just really happy that they held up
and they kept the shape,
'cause that was the one thing
that I was really worried about.
These kind of look like baguettes,
but, no, they are big giant cookies.
I just don't want it to be ruined.
So I have made an executive decision
to pour it over instead of dipping it in,
because I feel like they're
just too fragile to be dipped.
Oh, she feels thick,
but she feels pourable.
So here we go.
Ooh.
(Tway gasps)
(gentle jazz music)
I love this green color.
Okay, visually, this looks so good.
Next, I'm gonna do the cookies and cream
and it's going right on top
of the chocolate shortbread.
They look so good,
but they have these
little bubbles in there.
So I'm gonna gently tap this.
Alright, so let's do a
comparison right now.
This is the matcha.
Twins!
Then this is the cookies and cream.
So I'm looking at the Oreo right now,
and it looks like there's more
of these speckled in there.
I'm going to add some
of these crumbled Oreos
onto the cookies and cream.
Good job. You're doing great.
Now, I have the strawberry
and the chocolate left to do.
The clock is still ticking,
so I can't mess up here.
I gotta move quick.
Just gonna lightly tap to
remove these little bubbles.
I'm looking at the strawberry right now,
and it has little specks
of strawberry in there.
So I am going to use this
strawberry dust from earlier.
I'm just gonna dust it right
over the top of the strawberry.
Here are my version of
the giant Pocky sticks.
I have cookies and cream,
matcha,
chocolate,
and strawberry.
These four turned out great.
I gotta make four more
and let them rest for an hour
and then I can party with Jasmine.
Here it is, my version
of giant Pocky sticks,
all boxed up,
and I'm ready to party.
Jasmine, come on out, please.
- Oh my god, Lindsay!
Thank you.
Thank you. This is the best birthday ever.
- Happy birthday!
(Jasmine exclaims)
- Oh my god. It's a party of two.
- Exactly.
Matcha, chocolate, strawberry,
and cookies and cream.
- This literally looks like
the exact replica of Pocky.
When I was a kid,
this is exactly what I hoped to be eating.
- So do you wanna dig in?
- Yes.
- How should we eat this?
- My inner child wants to just take it out
and take a big bite into it.
- Okay.
Let's do it.
Okay. Cheers.
- Cheers.
(whimsical music)
- This is big Pocky.
- It's really good.
- This is making me feel...
(Tway laughs)
You're ready. My god.
(dramatic music)
(high-pitched tone)
- Wow.
They're like baguettes.
- But big cookie.
(both laugh)
Mm.
- The matcha is really good.
- Now you try this one.
- Okay. Here.
- These are so luxurious.
- [Tway] They really are.
- Like elevated Pocky.
Tway, this has been such
an amazing birthday gift.
Thank you so much.
- Of course.
Thank you so much for the challenge.
I can now say that I
have made my own version
of big old giant Pocky sticks.
Thanks for watching.
In the comments,
let me know what I should make big next,
and I'll see you next time.
Peace.
- Peace.
(mellow music)